j'ordonne canet ste connaît bien les
contrastes mais à formerie au coeur des
sables bitumineux de l'alberta il est
maintenant installée à victoria
un petit coin de paradis qui sur les
questions environnementales semble faire
bonne figure mais qui a aussi son lot de
contradictions
on redoutait le déversement qui pourrait
se produire à montréal dit il se produit
quotidiennement ici chaque jour ce sont
80 millions de litres d'eaux usées de la
région qui sont déversés dans l'océan
l'eau ne subit aucun traitement
préliminaire toutes les bactéries ne
sont donc pas éliminer si certains
scientifiques ont avancé au cours des
années que les effets sur l'océan et la
santé étaient minimes de plus en plus de
gens à victoria crois qu'ils ont un
devoir moral d'agir au début des années
2000 mascotte a fait son apparition
question faire pression pour que la
région se dote d'une usine de traitement
des eaux usées
les critiques sont aussi venues des
voisins américains pas plus tard qu'en
nous un grand journal de siat oppressé
victoria de régler un problème politique
qualifiée de constipé on parle de
construire une usine de traitement des
eaux depuis des années mais le projet
est bloqué on ne s'entend pas sur
l'endroit où la bâtir nous avions
presque à environ deux ans maintenant
point les autorités la région assure
toutefois qu'il ya du progrès dans le
dossier
ottawa n'a jamais sévi contre victoria
en 2012 le gouvernement fédéral lui a
plutôt octroyé 250 millions de dollars
pour construire son usine avant 2020
le déversement quotidien des rejets des
goûts dans l'océan n'est pas un des
principaux enjeux électoraux dans une
circonscription qui ironiquement est
l'une des seules ou pays où la lutte est
très serrée entre le npd et le parti
vert
le député sortant néo-démocrate a refusé
de nous parler sur cette question
funding sa principale adversaire dit que
le défi est maintenant de s'assurer que
le financement fédéral demeure même si
l' usine tarde à voir le jour
question que ses côtes puisse redevenir
source d'engouement et dans l'embarras
ici rafale bouvier auclair radio-canada
victoria